hey guys this is another video request
some of you asked me hey Daniel please
give us a few tips on how to become an
Instagram model is it worth it can we
make money how do you collab with other
people and brands and how do you get
followers and there's a lot more
questions so in this video that's
exactly what I'm gonna talk about so
let's get to it she's very quick if your
first time here on my channel I'm
Danielle and welcome to DLN model
lifestyle consider subscribing and also
clicking that notification valve say
won't miss any of the next videos now
let's talk about Instagram through this
whole video I'm gonna use my Instagram
account as an example and this is my
handle here if you want to follow me
along while I explain the tips now the
cool thing about being an Instagram
model is that you don't need to be a
certain height or a certain size and
there are different types of model like
fashion models commercial models fitness
models and so forth now if you're a new
beginner a fashion model or a commercial
model if you have a model agency you
need to work on your Instagram account
why well because most clients today I
want to know your Instagram account as
well they want to check out how many
followers you have and what your
personality like and when you go to a
casting usually we just go to a casting
and they look at your portfolio and you
do maybe a few poses with their clothes
on it take some photos but now they
sometimes ask you your Instagram
information as well and having a good
Instagram account and a good following
why just give you the edge to book a job
and some clients today also direct book
models just based on their Instagram
accounts you don't even need to go to a
casting a lot of models out there don't
like it but that is the world that we
live in today you can either go of it or
kick against it alright so let me start
with the real tips and advice to help
you if your Instagram account
can you really make money as an
Instagram model yes you can but you need
to grow the amount of followers you have
first and I'm not gonna lie to you like
other videos it is not gonna be as easy
as a lot of people say it is but I'm
gonna give you a few good tips that will
help you to increase your following a
little bit later on in the video but
first let's have a look at how you can
make money with Instagram if your
Instagram page looks good if you have a
good following and clients or brands
will reach out to you by themselves and
ask you for a collab and some might even
offer you free products in exchange for
a post on your Instagram but it is very
very very important that you need to
know your worth so how do you determine
your worth how do you know how much
money should you ask a brand for a
sponsored post or even a story well
there's a few good websites that you can
use that works out a fair price for you
and for the sponsor I personally use
social Bluebook because it is super easy
to use with no hiccups you just upload
your Instagram info and they work out a
price based on your followers amount the
interaction on post and so forth now
this is my Instagram account and as you
can see this is the suggested price for
a post or a story and as you can see I'm
very honest in this video but my
Instagram account is not as huge as
other youtubers because I only really
started to focus on YouTube when I
started my youtube channel which is
around a year and eight months ago I've
also started another one just a few
months ago and so my two YouTube
channels is my priority and I use most
of my time to create videos for you guys
and so I don't have a lot of time to
create post on Instagram I personally
only get to around 3 to 4 posts a week
but I'll get back to that a little bit
later the bigger your Instagram account
is the bigger the amount gets that
brands need to pay you for a sponsored
post in your feet or on stories but be
very careful who you say yes to now as
you can see I don't really do sponsored
videos on my Instagram and also not on
YouTube
why because I'm not really that guy that
just wants to make money from brands I
mean there's a lot of brands out there
that is crappy to be honest and I care
more about being honest and keeping the
trust of my followers on Instagram and
my subscribers on YouTube I might do
sponsored videos and post on Instagram
in the future but only if I really trust
the brand and so should you if you
become an Instagram model choose the
brand's you want to collab with very
carefully now in the beginning if you
want to look for sponsors or for brands
then there's a few websites that you can
look into that are full of companies and
brands that are looking for influencers
or Instagram models like yourself to
show their products and make it known to
the people out there in the world some
of these websites are aspire IQ trend
heaps II hyped up and many others but
none of this really helps you if you
don't have an impressive Instagram
account that looks professional and that
has a lot of followers so let me give
you a few tips on how to improve your
Instagram page
define clearly who you are people
wouldn't follow you if they don't have
any idea what you're about there's a
billion active users on Instagram every
month so you got to think how are you
gonna stand out well let's look at what
happens when people click on our
Instagram account what do they first see
they need to see exactly who you are for
example when people land on my page I
have a professional profile photo and
immediately they can see that I am a
youtuber and an international model and
they can also see my channel in this
link so once people check your bio what
do they do next they usually go to your
feet to see what content they can expect
to see from you and if they like it they
will follow you quality content is king
don't just post anything just because
you feel like it focus on quality a lot
of models just post selfies all the time
but there's thousands millions of other
people who post selfies all the time and
that is not working on Instagram today
anymore you have to share what makes you
you
what do you believe in what is your
hobbies what is your niche are you a
vegan are you only interested in fashion
do you believe in God or nothing on my
page for example you see videos because
I have two YouTube channels this one
that you're watching right now and a new
channel called The Ellen Christian
lifestyle so people can see that on my
page second they can see I'm a model
because of my modeling photos and number
three and I love to bring value to
people's lives by posting motivational
quotes that inspire people and also
share my faith in God some people will
like my content and some people won't
it's gonna be the exact same thing for
you but you need to let people know who
you really are because only then you
will start to get more followers when
people understand who you are and what
you believe in so if you want to be an
Instagram model the main bulk of your
content needs to be about modeling so
modeling photos about yourself but then
combine it with your personal interest
but don't go too big here keep it small
don't just post everything you believe
in the world and about all your hobbies
and about everything because then it
just becomes confusing choose one or two
main
things that people can identify with
mine for example is my faith and then my
motivational messages and quotes and
then also I share my home life my
personal life where I show a little bit
of my dog and my wife and my family
you got a post consistently if you have
the time unlike me you only have enough
time for three or four post a week you
have to at least post once everyday on
your feed and one to two times on your
stories if you don't post content
regularly how are people gonna find you
use more hashtags and geo tags this is
extremely important to know how to use
it because if you don't use your
hashtags to right way and geo tags how
are people going to find you you need to
use it the right way if you want to grow
and you can use around I think 30
hashtags in a post but the way you post
it also needs to be done nicer like for
example if you have 30 hashtags all over
your post
it looks very ugly so what you can do is
use three dots and then you put your
hashtags thirty is a little bit too much
but ten to fifteen hashtags are the
sweet spot for text and then use
hashtags that are relevant to your posts
and then geez short and just general
hashtag like model use longer and more
specific hashtags so for example instead
of just using model use male modeling
photos or male modeling or male modeling
poses or modeling tips now jute axe is
also important for brands and people to
find you if they are looking in a
certain area and that will give you more
followers and also a local brand might
sponsor you for a post you gotta tag
brands and other Instagram accounts why
is this so important well because if you
tag other Instagram accounts it gets you
out there even more and they might
repost your posts which then brings you
in more followers and if your brand sees
it they might to partner with you as
well and sponsor you for posts in the
future but remember these posts should
be high quality you don't need a super
camera you can just use your phone but
learn how to take good quality photos
with your phone
you gotta grow organically Instagram is
changing so people out there and brands
they can clearly see if you have fake
followers and that damages your
reputation so don't get fake followers
rather focus on growing your Instagram
account organically get followers that
are really interested in you and what
you post I personally have never bought
any followers because I feel it's
dishonest so my advice to use to also
just stay who you are and if you don't
have fake followers then brands will
trust you a lot more to show their
products on your page right Instagram
captions then just post something with
just the photo there and not explaining
what you're doing where you are how you
feeling
people are interested in that because I
connect with you so describe the posts
that you're doing the photos so that
people can interact with you in the
comments and then you can also even ask
questions to even get that a whole
conversation starting instagrams
algorithm loves it and they will push
your post a little bit more if they see
that you have good interaction on your
post and a lot of likes I explain a lot
of things in my posts to explain my
worldviews and also to encourage other
people to be better
connect and hustle it's like time to
interact with other people on Instagram
to connect with them and to build those
relationships especially if you're new
to Instagram sometimes if you follow
people they will follow you back and
they will check out your content
another huge tip is to follow and
unfollow big celebrities that has
millions of followers
when you click follow some of the other
people are able to see your photo there
or your account there for a few seconds
and if it looks interesting to them they
will click on it and if they like what
they see they will follow you I tested
this out a while back and I downloaded a
program called GES auto clicker so while
I was sleeping that program followed an
unfollowed a certain celebrity and then
in the morning when I woke up I had 70
250 more followers than I usually would
get overnight but now it only works for
a few hours because Instagram found a
way to counter that as well but it's not
wrong because you don't get fake
followers it just gets you seen because
it's normal people who go and then they
just see your profile and if they're
curious enough they will click on it and
follow you so you can give it a try as
well
just a bonus tip work with a plan
Instagram can take a lot of time out of
you especially if you don't have an
action plan to post your content for
example I post three types of content on
my feet and each type is in the same
column which then keeps it organized but
also keeps it more appealing to my
followers first I post pictures with
quotes or motivational messages on them
and then I post photos of my personal
life and modeling and then third I post
short clips of my new videos on YouTube
so that people will be notified of a new
video and know what to expect so take a
look at your Instagram and think how can
I improve this by having an action plan
for my posts now remember there's a lot
of fake people on Instagram don't be one
of them and don't go crazy just to
impress people on Instagram just to get
likes because your value as a human
being is not determined by the number of
followers or likes you get on Instagram
just be yourself and improve the unique
talents that you already have now if you
want to know how to look better on
photos then this video will help you out
cheers guys
[Music]